michel piccoli dans mauvais sang de leos
carax 7 aujourd'hui sur vos écrans mais
ne quittait pas michel piccoli dans la
puritaine c'est mercredi prochain
michel piccoli dans soir 3 c'est
maintenant tout à l'heure henry chapier
vous a parlé de mauvais sang samedi
dernier ce soir nous parlerons de la
puritaine la puritaine signé jacques
doillon un père metteur en scène de
théâtre
piccoli retrouve sa fille sandrine
bonnaire en présence de sa compagne
sabine azéma les retrouvailles du père
et de la fille c'est toute l'histoire du
film que les blondes
3 les intérêts 4,9 rebonds des sags les
soucis comme ça basculait 6
une fois cette une seule de cet ami
l'ailé bénin elle me ressemble
c'est comme ça
toi tu voulais pas rater non plus et où
dix mois on veut pas de combat oui ce
qu'être guérir et d'en mourir comme le
crétin et lapins bleus
héros moi cela fit sur la bouche
d'affilée tout changer ni rien n'a
changé chelbi colis bonsoir vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que vous aviez envie
de parler des films des autres mais vous
avez quand même parler des veaux c'est
moi j'ai envie de vous embêter en vous
demandant si vous avez préféré mauvais
sens où la puritaine je serais incapable
de vous répondre et je vous répondrai
que j'ai une passion pour les deux cela
dit la curie le mauvais sens commence à
vivre sa carrière devant le public
depuis 6h depuis 14 heures ça y est ils
vivent il n'a plus besoin de nous il ya
qques le public mais vous y est quand
même pour beaucoup parce que justement
dans votre carrière
on remarque chaque fois que les choses
vont très bien vous coupez c'est
intéressant ça par exemple en 70 vous
auriez pu vous contenter avec les films
de sautet d'en rester là
et puis vous aider les jeunes six ans
devant je voudrais dire qu'au temps pour
jacques doillon que pour léo carax vous
leur prêtez à la fois la légende piccoli
et quelque chose d'autre non oui
j'espère d'abord je ne me contente
jamais faut jamais se contenter
je n'ai qu'un souhait fois j'en ai
beaucoup de souhaits mais ça ne retourne
de retravailler avec claude sautet qu
avec doyon nous avons une c'est le
deuxième film seulement que nous faisons
ensemble mais c'est quand même déjà un
long parcours que nous avons fait et
avec kkr axe c'est un nouveau chemin
c'est une nouvelle aventure qui va
peut-être me mener ponant je sais pas je
ne travaillais plus vous êtes en train
plus jamais ensemble
mais ça m'étonnerait comme ça gdg plein
d'amour fidèles ya une chose qui est
importante pour vous je crois c'est le
renouveau de cinéma français on se
lamente chaque fois avec kara comme avec
doyon ils revivent faut le dire
peut-être ce soir
oui hé hé hé hé doyon et bouleversant
parce que
il ya une nouvelle donne dans ce film
doyon il ya une ouverture doyon
l'amoureux de l'hystérie s'ouvre vers
une tendresse complexe bien sûr mais
bouleversante
vous allez déjà joué un rôle de père qui
a retrouvé sa fille avec doyon c'était
ça en famille les jeunes oui mais cet
état c'était un film austère et
complètement introverti là c'est allé
d'histoire qu'on a peur et d'une fille
mais c'est une fille et apple qui y
mettent en scène leurs retrouvailles ils
mettent en scène leur amour ils mettent
en scène leurs secrets 1° lydie ce matin
que vous incarnez dans caract tout le
mythe du vieux grand-père du pathé est
ce que vous êtes d'accord que ce film là
c'est à la fois le lien entre ce passé
et l'avenir d'un autre cinéma qui
passent à travers les autres personnages
tout à fait d'ailleurs leos carax avant
le tournage m'avait fait m'avait donné
beaucoup de photocopies de tous ces
grands acteurs américains qui avaient
joué les grands héros gangsters et aussi
me faisait passer des bandes sonores de
la voix de ses héros du passé qui nous
font encore rêver alors une une question
seulement vous avez dit à quelqu'un
d'autre je ne sais plus là je ne vois
pas ce que je vais faire comme fils vous
aurez avait fait 120 et vous avez envie
d'en faire mille alors je vous dire la
vérité après le film de leos carax
mauvais sens parce qu'il ya vos papiers
troll une confusion et celui de doyon
qui s'appelle la puritaine
j'hésite entre deux choses ou dire
maintenant ça y est je vous annonce que
j'ai fait mes adieux et ces deux films
ou alors repartir de plus belle alors le
deuxième scoop ce que je vais repartir
le plus bel hiver et il ya un film qui
va sortir bientôt je crois vous pouvez
nous en parler vous venez de tourner
noah oui alors bien sûr il faut que tout
le monde se précipite pour aller voir le
film de leos carax et de jacques doillon
puisque j'y participe
mais indirectement de coeur aussi je
participe à un film admirable qui va
sortir aussi le
le 3 décembre en notant que le film de
doillon il est contradictoire de faire
la publicité pour deux films qui vont
être concurrents c'est le sixième jour
de youssef chahine
c'est un film bouleversant d'une
drôlerie extraordinaire imaginez un
metteur en scène égyptien lyrique ce
qu'ils fassent un film dédié jean kelly
et qui a le culot de faire évoluer un
jeune personnage égyptiens comme un jean
kelly je rappelle simplement à ceux qui
nous écoutent que ce metteur en scène la
fée bonaparte avec vous un film qui a
été présenté à cannes pour bien
identifier chailly dont nous avons parlé
ici avec dalila super d'un alien mais
croyez moi on n'a ni papam pas fini de
parler de bonaparte et on n'a pas fini
de parler de chaussée du de youssef
chahine lit de michel piccoli si vous
êtes des regrettés de qui jouent alors
si vous regrettez de pouvoir jim kelly à
l'écran allez voir mort ces mots aydin
le nouveau john kelly échangèrent nous
nous conseillons d'aller voir vos deux
films et vous vous nous conseiller
d'aller voir le sixième jour donnera
trois fois au signal g cause a été
remercié
on peut aussi remercier les prêts